dude I got to say before we get started
your new book is absolutely phenomenal
it feels like it was written
purposefully for me your ability to
weave a story into a lesson is ungodly
and everybody needs to go and buy same
as ever right now it's one of the best
things that I've read in a very long
time that makes me so happy to hear and
maybe it was written for the show maybe
I wrote it just for this episode right
now that we're doing who knows yes yes I
knew it I knew it I knew that you
dedicated years of your life to just me
my only child my inner only child is
coming out again oh also got to show uh
the Rangers going to the World Series so
I am uh repping
appropriately the purpose of your book
same as ever is to kind of as far as I
can see explain to people the underlying
uh principles and rules like the
thermodynamics of life that doesn't
change but a lot of the time people
focus on things that they think won't
change but will so what do most people
get wrong when they're making
predictions well it's it's pretty well
known that particularly in finance and
economics but also in politics things
like that we're so bad at predicting
predicting the next recession predicting
when the stock market's going to fall
predicting who's going to win the
election it's not just bad it's abysmal
it's absolutely disastrous and so I've
been a financial writer for 17 years and
a big part of what I've focused on is
just trying to answer the question like
why are we so bad at this and why does
nobody care that we're so bad at this
despite the track AR people keep doing
it over and over again and one of the
one of the ideas that I that I stumbled
across was just the idea that and it's
it's it's kind of ironic in tongue and
cheek but it's not that we're bad at
predicting it's that we're actually very
good at predicting except for the
surprises and the surprises are tend to
be like virtually all that matter over
time and so part of me was when I just
accepted how terrible we are at
predicting there's two with there's two
things that you can do after that you
can become a grump about it and just say
just just become a cynic and say there's
nothing we can do nobody knows anything
by humbug or you can say okay actually
are there things that never change that
we put all of our weight into and I
think if you look over history across
any field in history business economics
entertainment medicine Politics the
themes that repeat themselves over and
over again once you start looking for
them they're everywhere and it's always
like the characters change but it's the
same movie over and over again and once
you focus on that and then you marry
that with this idea that we can't
predict the change nobody can nobody's
ever been able to do it nobody ever will
be able to do it because they're all
surprising
and then you marry that with there's
actually all these facets of human
behavior that never change all right so
let's put all of our emphasis and our
new view of the Future Let's only focus
on what we know is never going to change
and there could be literally thousands
of those bits of human behavior that
never changed for the book I focused on
23 that I thought were powerful to me
and that I thought I had stories to tell
about of these things that like look
regardless of what happens in the future
we know that these things are going to
be part of it regardless of which
direction which path we go down it's so
interesting to think about the Common
Thread that ties all of this together
being the idiot shaven Apes that kind of
inhabit it the world can be different
there can be a catastrophe or not it can
be peace time or wartime there can be a
depression or it can be the the greatest
wealth creation period in history but
ultimately humans are always going to
respond with the same fear and greed and
envy and lack of altruism and focus on
their own self first I had I know quote
Neil Ferguson at the start of the book
and I had him on a couple of weeks ago
and I asked him just how accurate is the
quote history doesn't repeat itself but
it often Rhymes and he called it doubly
wrong he said not only is it not right
it's also not what Mark Twain said so
just in case anybody needed a final sort
of nail in the coffin of that yeah
you've got this great quote as well you
say to know where we're going you have
to know where we've been but the more
realistic is admitting that if you know
where we've been you realize we have no
no idea where we're going events
compound in unfathomable ways I mean
there's so many there's so many little
stories in history where you realize how
fragile history is and whether it's the
start of World War II or 911 or Co you
realize that there would have been just
a little tiny no nothing change in
circumstances that nobody paid any
attention to that would have utterly
transformed everything one of the
stories I tell in the book came from
David McCulla who is a a historian died
not too long ago but he was one of the
foremost authorities on the
Revolutionary War and I know I'm I'm an
American talking to a Brit this is going
to get really awkward here for a second
I'm I'm an immigrant to this great
nation I survived two Fourth of July
without getting into an existential
crisis I'm okay well let's say bygones
be byon let's talk about the
Revolutionary War uh there's there's a
scene where David McCulla says there was
a period in the Revolutionary War where
the the British had George Washington
cornered uh just outside of Long Island
and all they had to do was sail up the
East River in New York and George
Washington would have been quartered it
all would have been over and but they
couldn't do it because the winds were
blowing in the wrong direction last
night they could not sail up the East
River which gave George Washington just
enough time to get away and David
McCulla was asked he said if the winds
were blowing in the other direction that
night would there be a United States of
America and he said no it never would
have happened like the entire existence
of this country relied on the winds
blowing One Direction This One Night in
the 1700s and if you take that out and
you can tell similar stories about the
start of World War I World War II the
Civil War there's all these the more you
dig into it you realize how fragile
history is and then you have to accept
if history is that fragile well the
future is too there's going to be all
these little no nothing the equivalent
of the wind blowing in the wrong
direction that's happening today that
will completely spiral into this God
knows unknown story 10 or 20 years into
the future and it's just a plea for
humility like when when you piece
together how fragile the past is you
realize that we have absolutely no clue
some of the finer details of what's
going to happen in the future yeah if
you know where we've been you realize we
have no idea where we're going each big
story could have been turned out
differently if it had a few little puffs
of nothingness going in the other
direction it's uh I think people want to
have a sense of control and certainty
about the future and it's disquieting to
realize just how much random chance gets
thrown into this and that's kind of what
a lot of people didn't like the fact
that Neil
said the cycles of history aren't really
Cycles the only things that are the same
of the humans because it makes us feel
uncertain and we go oh my God like maybe
maybe I'm not going to be able to
predict what happens next and he goes
well yeah previously could you have
predicted what happened then what was
that thing about um uh about the
depression like how many people were
able to predict the depression zero
exactly zero People Robert Schiller from
yell University won the Nobel prize in
economics he devoted a big chunk of his
career to working with economic
historians to find one person who
predicted the Great Depression and they
could find a couple people who would say
we're look you know the economy is due
to to decline or due for a recession but
who predicted the Great Depression 0.0
people and of course that was that was
the biggest economic event of the
century and so and look people were
pretty well informed back then it it's
not that people were running around
oblivious to what was happening everyone
knew the stock market was crazy everyone
knew things were stretched here but the
chain of events that actually turned the
decline into the Great Depression could
not have been foreseen I mean the the B
not to go not to go down too much of a
rabbit hole here but what really made
the Great Depression awful was the
banking crisis it wasn't the stock
market crash it wasn't necessarily the
Dust Bowl it was once the bank started
failing all hell broke loose and the
banking crisis really began in Austria
when there was a big bank called credit
onsa that went out of business and you
can literally track it on a map that the
banking wave spread across the world it
went from Austria to Paris to London and
eventually made its way to New York and
then spread throughout the rest of the
United States and it's literally like
you can you can draw a straight line
from this Austrian bank in 1931 going
out of business to a guy in the middle
of Ohio losing his job it's not the kind
of thing that somebody in 1925 could
have predicted it was such a crazy chain
of events that made it all happen
yeah you've got this nice summation we
are very good at predicting the future
except for the
surprises and and the next line of that
was and the surprises tend to be all
that matter over time it tends to be
like if you look at the big events that
have really moved the needle in history
for the last 80 years in the United
States at least it's Pearl Harbor
September 11th Co those are the things
that like we woke up one morning and we
said oh [__] the world is not the same
the world is not the same place it was
yesterday and the common denominator of
those three events and you can add some
more to it are that nobody saw them
coming there were not there was no
economic Outlook a year before that said
get ready for 911 no nobody wrote that
in the year 2000 I write in the book
this crazy newscast that I came across
and it's from the morning of September
11th and it's like haunting to listen to
it it it it takes place about 20 minutes
before the attack takes place and it's
this newscaster I'm going to paraphrase
but she says good morning it's Tuesday
September September 11th beautiful day
here in New York City and the the side
like just she's completely oblivious to
what's about to happen 20 minutes later
which of course nobody could have seen
it coming and you can say with so much
certainty that the biggest news story of
the next year and the next five years
the next 10 years is something that
nobody is talking about today that
everyone's completely oblivious to
because it's always been like that it's
always been like that I mean just in
recent times how many people month ago
we talking about Hamas and and Israel
outside of that region zero nobody but
now it's the biggest new story in the
world same with two years ago with
Russia and Ukraine Co of course like
there's a great quote from Carl Richards
financial advisor he says risk is what
is left over when you think you've
thought of everything so you go out of
your way to try to view the future in
your own life and in the economy and
it's like great that's a good thing to
do and then after you have thought about
all the risks in your life the thing
that you're not thinking about the thing
that's not on that list is the one
that's actually going to do the most
damage because if it was on the list you
would have mitigated it in some way or
another you would prepare for it I mean
the perfect example of that is Y2K it's
not that it wasn't a risk but everyone
had been freaking out about it for five
years so when it happened everyone had
prepared for it the computers had been
changed whatever it was so compare Y2K
to 911 that nobody saw coming it's like
it's night and day who was that NASA
guy who's that the dude with a helmet
yes
yes re I want to hear I love that story
dude it was one of the best ones in the
book so it's a crazy story that I came
across I was reading I I had this kick a
couple years ago where I was really into
studying the Apollo missions because I
think walk going to the Moon is the
coolest thing humans have ever done it's
like the craziest the riskiest the most
the most ballsy and I came across this
little story and it was almost a foot
note but it one of those things where
you read it and you're like wait tell me
more about that that sounds fascinating
and what it was is before NASA went into
space on Rockets which were expensive
and dangerous they used to test a lot of
their equipment on these ultra high
altitude hot air balloons they had these
hot air balloons that could go up to
like 150,000 feet like basically the
edge of space and they would do it to
test a lot of their equipment so in July
of 1960 there was a uh US Air Force test
pilot his name was Victor Prather who
took the hot air balloon up to about
112,000 feet to test NASA's new suit it
was a suit that they eventually used in
the Gemini missions and he goes up suit
works great everything's perfect he's
heading back down to earth he starts
descending back down to earth and one of
the quirks of the suit that he was
wearing the space suit was that it was
very hot and stuffy to breathe in
particularly in in the Florida summer
heat as he's descending back down to
earth so when he was low enough to
breathe on his own which is like 5,000
feet he opened up the face plate on his
helmet just to catch some fresh air like
not not that big a deal he knows he's
low enough to breath on his own like who
cares the plan A in that situation is
that the hot air balloon would land on
the of an aircraft carrier that was what
they intended but a very wellknown and
well rehearsed Plan B is that he would
land in the ocean because it was it was
just hard to stick the landing on this
hot air balloon and so that's what
happens he lands in the ocean nobody's
panicking in that situation uh an Air
Force helicopter is going to hover over
him drop a rescue line that he attaches
to himself and gets pulled to safety as
he's doing that he slips and he falls
into the ocean and that too like was not
supposed to be that big a deal they had
rehearsed this and whatnot
but uh because the the the suit that he
was wearing was supposed to be
watertight and and buoyant he's supposed
to Bob in the water but since he had
opened up the face plate to his helmet
all a sudden he was not watertight and
as soon as he hits the water his suit
fills up with water and he sinks to the
bottom of the ocean and drowns and there
could be so many takeaways from this
story one of them that I think is just
Bonkers is that there are four NASA
astronauts who die in the mission
getting to the Moon all of them died on
Earth Earth which is just like crazy in
itself but the other that I think about
a lot is that um NASA is the most
planning Centric organization that's
ever existed like you don't go to the
Moon by crossing your fingers and hoping
for the best every imaginable risk that
they could think of was planned out and
they had plan A B and C contingencies
for how to mitigate that risk and in
their postmortem of what happened to
Victor prth when he drowned they said
something to the effect of we had
thought of every single risk
in this Mission except for the one thing
that mattered most which is that this
poor guy just wanted to get some fresh
air and that that I think that's the
definition of risk it's what's left over
when you think you've thought of
everything the other thing is like you
can imagine the planners for this
Mission planning about what ha I'm
making this up because I don't I don't
I'm not an engineer what happens if the
balloon pops what happens if we run out
of fuel whatever it might be you're not
going to plan what happens if this poor
guy wants to catch some fresh air right
there's another story that I wrote about
in the psychology of money that I
thought was was so ridiculous when I
read it it was during the Battle of
Stalingrad in World War II and there was
a division of German tanks uh out on the
rear lines and they got called up to the
front and it's like 20 or 30 tanks they
get called up to the front battle lines
all the tank commanders turn their tank
on I don't know if it's a key or a
button or whatever and none of them
start the the entire division of Tanks
their tanks don't start and they start
to research what the hell's going on
here and they realize that when the
tanks were sitting in reserve the field
mice outside of Stalingrad chewed
through the wires and then so they can't
so I use this an example too of like
imagine you're like an army General and
you're planning for what can go wrong
and what can go wrong is you get shot at
you get bombed you run out of food
nobody is like hey make sure that we
protect oursel from the mice in the
fields right it's always a thing that
you never see coming that's actually
going to pose the biggest risk I wonder
if those were specially trained sabater
mice
they were they were Soviet train mice
during that period that would be correct
so given the fact that risk is what is
left over after we think that we've
thought of
everything like what can we do about
risk how what should our relationship
with risk be like given that as you say
I mean do people become nihilistic and
just stop caring about risk at all do
people become uh overly risk averse and
try to stay clear of stuff what's your
relationship to risk like I I do think
there's some balance between those two I
I I think the honest answer to your
question is this is why the world is
risky and it's always going to be risky
and there is not much we can do about it
I think that's that's the honest answer
if there is a more technical answer that
I think particularly as it pertains to
finance it's that if you are only
planning for and saving for the risks
that you can Envision by definition
you're going to miss the surprise every
single time and so I I tend to have
quite a bit of cash as a percentage of
my net worth and there have been a lot
of people who would ask like like what
are you saving for and my answer is
always I don't know because of course if
I was only planning for things that I
could Envision oh I'm going to need a
new car here and my kids are going to go
to college then you're always going to
miss the equivalent of Pearl Harbor 911
coid every single time so the amount of
safety that you have it's it's not to
say be completely risk averse that's not
the point at all but the amount of
cushion that you have should feel like
it's too much because when it feels like
it's too much you say it should make you
wins it should make you a little bit
Yeah and because it like like like if it
feels like the right amount then you
know you're unprepared by definition
right so I guess the meta lesson here or
it sounds like is bake in more
contingency a greater buffer around your
current risk profile to attempt as best
you can to account for that which has
been left over that you haven't been
able to think of that's the only way to
do it and the other thing to to to
recognize is that the world usually
breaks about once per decade not not not
exactly on that timeline but pretty much
once per decade there's a big event
where like I said people wake up and
they say the world's not the same as as
it used to be so during that time when
your savings makes you wise you might
have to sit on a wincing amount of
savings for a decade but once a decade
you're going to realize it's the most
valuable asset you've ever had in your
life the first rule of happiness is low
expectations
why because every every bit of happiness
every every bit of joy that you're going
to get out of life is simply the gap
between your expectations and your
circumstances and you can show this very
cleanly by just pointing out things like
John de Rockefeller he was he was the
richest man who ever lived his adjusted
for inflation he was worth nearly half a
trillion dollars in his time but during
his entire life I think he died in 1933
or thereabouts he never had penicillin
sunscreen Advil to say nothing of the
internet or Communications of of any
kind like he lived a life that the
average ordinary American would look at
today and view as positively primitive
of course he had mansions and servants
and won that but in terms of the
technology he he took advantage of it
was a joke but no average American
should look at him today and say I live
better than Rockefeller because they
have Penicillin and sunscreen and Advil
because everything all those new
technologies just become the Baseline
that we accept and therefore that that's
just to say like you can go through a
period of life or the economy in general
where everything gets better technology
gets better medicine gets better
everyone becomes richer and nobody feels
any better off for it because you just
reset your expectations all along the
way and you could so imagine a world in
which my grandkids are earning three
times as much as me adjusted for
inflation and they're not any happier
whatsoever and the medical that
technology that they have let's just
assume they've cured cancer they've Cur
they've cured every they've cured every
disease and they're not any happier for
it because that just becomes the norm
just like you and I today by and large
don't think about malaria if if you told
somebody three years ago that we in the
developed world had more or less
eradicated malaria they would have they
would they could not fathom a world
being that glorious are you familiar
with are you familiar with the tville
Paradox of course yeah yeah that's
exactly what we're describing here yeah
living standards rise people's
expectations rise and then overtake the
actual living standards that's it and at
the micro level it happens too where you
know if if you get if you get a raise at
work but then with that raise you
automatically adjust your expectations
to the kind of house you need to live in
to the kind of car that you drive to the
kind of vacations that you take you
instantly that's why you get used to
these things so quickly it's not
necessarily that you become accustomed
to them it's that you raise your
Baseline of what you expect in them and
so look is it important to try to
increase your circumstances become
wealthier increase your net worth of
course duh but with just as much
emphasis you need to go out a way to
manage your expectations to keep them
low and recognize that it's the gap
between those two that's actually going
to bring you all the joy and happiness
in life so as a society there's there's
no way to do it it's always going to be
the case that society's expectations
increases that's the cheville Paradox at
the individual level I think you can at
least recognize the game that's being
played though and how ridiculous the
game is what's that is it a Monga quote
where he says the world is actually
driven by it's not driven by greed it's
driven by Envy that's it and and really
what Envy is is you're looking at your
neighbor who has a bigger house and
saying I want that that's all it is
which is just it's just an adjustment of
expectations in the 1950s which people
tend to remember as this glorious period
of prosperity the average new house
built was 920 square feet and today in
the United States it's like 2700 square
feet but people don't feel better off
and I and not only do not feel better
off the people who are moving into a
house that is two and a half times the
size of what we of what my grandparents
would have moved into probably feel like
they're falling behind oh my house is
2700 squ feet but on Instagram that
guy's house is 10,000 square feet kind
of thing it's just a constant
Readjustment of expectations part of
that by the way this is an important
thing here is great the fact that people
are generally unsatisfied is where
Innovation comes from the fact that
people wake up in the morning and say
I'm unsatisfied with my lot in life I
need to do better and figure out a
better way is why the world improves so
it's not to say that this is bad but
it's an explanation for why there can be
so much progress in your individual life
or throughout all society and nobody
feels any better for it have I given you
my bit on the mistranslation of the
Buddha have I given you this one yet no
no let's so uh this is from Robert wries
why Buddhism is true and in it uh life
is suffering is commonly quoted as
coming from the Buddha but Scholars
contest that the translation is actually
wrong and the final word which is Dua du
KK ha uh isn't translated as suffering
but
unsatisfactoriness life is
unsatisfactoriness now I often think
about um this imaginary couple that I
have a vurus relationship with every
time I think of this thing so they plan
a holiday they know that they're going
to go away and both of them are big into
putting their itinerary together and
they know exactly the hotel that they're
going to go to and they look at the menu
of the hotel of the hotel bar and of the
restaurant that they're going to go to
and they know the exact table they're
going to sit at and they know that the
sun sets and they've imagined it and
they've thought about and they've
organized the kennel to look after the
dog and then they fly out and they get
there and they sit down and then the
wife sits down and she's facing the Sun
but the sun's actually a little bit low
and it's sort of glancing off the water
and it's it's a little bit bright for
her eyes and they got this cocktail but
they wish that they'd got it on the
Rocks instead of Blended and there was
some sand between her toes from walking
on the beach a little bit early run life
is unsatisfactoriness it is baked Into
Your Existence that things are just
going to be on average a bit [__]
than you hope they would and even if
they outdid your
expectation very quickly you're going to
be looking over the current moment's
shoulder just trying to see what's
coming next 100% I mean and and by the
way I love the phrase just a bit [__]
than you expected that's a that's a
wonderful price I think a lot of this
too is that you get the most dopamine
from anticipation it's not by actually
achieving it you get the dopamine by
dreaming about it so of course it's well
known that the best part of a summer
vacation is the anticipation of it but
actually going on it is not didn't
Ferris have a a hack where he would him
and his family would book like the next
half decade of holidays I'm pretty sure
that he did that he would just be like
well okay if enjoyment is in the
anticipation if I get more anticipation
that means more enjoyment from the same
experience and I'm I'm pretty sure that
there was a period where he had like
five years of holidays and and and
Resorts and trips and flights and
everything else booked book booked out
for precisely that reason that's so
smart I I've had these ridiculous
moments in the past I'm sure others have
something similar of I'll be on vacation
I'll be in Maui with my family and it's
day one we just get there and I'm
standing on the balcony watching the
sunset and thinking to myself wouldn't
it be so great if we could come back
here next year like like even though I'm
I'm literally right there what gives me
the most pleasure is thinking about
coming back and then I instantly have
this recognition of just like this is so
absurd but that's how your brain works
because thinking about coming back is
going to give you more dopamine than
actually the fact that you're there in
the
moment Do's an interesting Insight from
Gad sadd's new book on happiness that uh
the amount of sex that makes somebody
happiest is an adequate amount based on
kind of an overall Baseline but what's
most important is that you're having a
little bit more sex than most of your
friends are based on their
self-reporting and you've got this
phenomenal quote which I think kind of
summarizes where we're at there is no
such thing as objective wealth
everything is relative and most relative
to those around you there is no such
thing as objective wealth is phenomenal
and it it's so true given the fact that
okay are people today with all of the
advantages that we have a hundred years
hence better off than John D Rockefeller
well no one's going to say that no
workingclass American that that's living
paycheck to paycheck is going to feel
like they're more blessed than what was
once the richest man potentially who
ever lived apart from masa Musa or
whatever that dude was it's no one's
going to feel like that and yet
objectively there are arguments that you
can have on both sides right you know
there's as as most comedians do they
really get to the point there's this
great Chris Rock skit where he says if
Bill Gates woke up with Oprah's money he
jump out the window and slit his wrist
on the way down and that's just to show
that all wealth is so relative and so I
yeah once once it's framed like that
there's this other quote from monu who
said this 300 years ago back to things
that never change he said if if you wish
to be happy that could very easily be
achieved but most people want to be
happier than other people and that is
difficult because we overestimate how
happy other people are so that's the
thing too it's not about how much you
have it's just where do you sit on the
relative lot and from an evolutionary
standpoint of course that's the case
because we're competing against each
other for resources and for mates so of
course it doesn't matter how much I have
it just matters that I have more than
you not you in particular but you know
so this must relate to fame and status
as as well beyond just
finances yeah there I I I I forget who
said this quote but there's I read
something recently that said it's so
tragic that humans are not wired for
happiness they're wired for status
that's what we're going after it's not
what can I do to make me happier it's
what can I do that puts me ahead of the
other people and I think for there's
actually a lot of people early on in
their career that really get this wrong
in the sense of they might have a skill
I'm really good at Microsoft Office yes
but so is everybody else on relative
terms that means absolutely nothing and
people over uh they they overestimate
that how rare their skills are and then
they get to the job market and they
their first salary sucks and they're not
they're not that useful and they can't
figure it out it's because the skills
that they have everybody else has them
too in relative terms they're zero and
so that's that's that's really true it's
true in investing too where it's like it
it doesn't matter if you have a lot of
information it all that matters is the
information that you have that others
don't and and that number for most
investors is zero the information that
you have that others don't doesn't exist
there's no information that you have
about the stock that others don't and
that's why it's so hard to beat the
market over time everything is just
relative to what other people have and
what other people are doing I've got
this idea at the moment about trajectory
being more important than position and
it's literally the same lesson but from
a status Fame uh perspective so if you
are the number two in the world but but
last year were number
one there is way less sexiness and
clamor around you than if you're number
150 but last year you were 300 and
there's something about our prediction
engine being able to kind of move out
let's extrapolate into the future
exactly where this person's going to end
up and what they're going to do and
there's this sort of Allure of what's
trendy something else that's going on
specifically with that which is someone
who is a an appreciating stock as
opposed to to a declining stock even if
that absolute position is lower it tells
you more about the current sentiment
right now and because our availability
bias and our window of what we're seeing
is so dependent on the moment we over
index for the person who is on the climb
but lower as opposed to the person who's
maybe at the top but not staying there
there's this great quote from Will Smith
in his biography where he says becoming
famous is the most amazing feeling in
the world being famous is a mixed bag
and losing Fame is a pain like you've
never felt before and like to I think
it's true for wealth too that becoming
wealthier like your net worth Rising is
amazing being wealthy just having a high
net worth is like is okay and losing
wealth is is terrible it's always just
the change in circumstances that you're
after like you like most people get more
joy and pleasure out of gaining wealth
than they do having wealth dude they're
going to be happier when it's going up
than when they actually have it you
weren't going to guess this but Andrew
Tate said it best not one for quoting
Andrew tape but I do love this quote
from him and he
says having things isn't fun getting
things is fun there's a great quote from
Drake too where he says people respect
you more when you are chasing something
not when you have
it so good yeah I think it applies to
virtually everything and it just it it
it kind of boils down to isn't life just
one big competition we're just trying to
get ahead and it's kind of a sad thing
to come to terms with and I think there
are ways to combat that at the indiv
individual level and not always be on
the rat race but just enjoy what you
have inside of your own head but at the
at the at the society level it has
always been like that and always will be
i' mentioned before we started I was
with Dan Bilzerian this weekend and I
rolled this trajectory as more important
than position thing to him and he seemed
to agree too and I said I wonder if
there's an argument to be made made that
rapid changes in status and wealth and
Accolade and Prestige are actually to be
avoided almost at all costs because what
you're doing is you're now resetting
that Baseline as you mentioned that's so
good yeah so
I'm not like slow life strategy but slow
success strategy trying as best you can
to just pulled Pok this thing out a
little bit let's just spread out you
know I'm not going to I'm not going to
go and get the car that I've always
wanted immediately why don't I get a car
that's halfway between it you know let's
it's strange because we want success we
don't want to leave anything on the
table we want to feel like we're
actualizing we want to maximize whatever
we can bring to the world and yet the
quicker that we do that all that we're
really doing is condemning a future
version of ourselves to have a higher
bar to jump over right I mean the
perfect example of that everyone knows
the long history of lottery winners
either going bankrupt or being miserable
afterwards like I know recently cuz the
lotteries now get ridiculous there was
someone who was like a very modest Blue
Collar working worker I imagine this
person was making 40 $50,000 a year and
they won a billion dollars in the
lottery and that honestly to go from
making 40 Grand to getting a check for a
billion dollars has got to be the the
biggest mind [__] that you can imagine
and I don't mean that in a good way I
think I think I think that that is is
something that on net it's it's
ridiculous to say I know it sounds crazy
but on net that's going to be that's
that's a psychological burden could be
could it could be one of the most
difficult things that you've ever had to
deal with in your life rips I had this
idea as well about
um guys like Jordan Peterson and Brett
Weinstein and Eric Weinstein you know
people who for a long time were
academics working in the dusty annals of
some place and then they get ripped out
of obscurity by some bold MMA
commentator and before they know it
they're you know heavily scrutinized and
people care about what they think and oh
my God I need to comment on the Ukraine
and let's get involved in the trans
issue like they had we we we often talk
about the Perils of Fame to young but we
never talk about the Perils of Fame too
old right like young Fame is you never
got the chance to work out what it's
like to be a normal person you turned
into McCauley culin or whatever but like
more old Fame is you thought you knew
who you were and your sense of self has
been completely ripped away from what
you actually your your entire conception
uh the way that people see you how much
they care about what you've got to say
you decades and decades and Decades of
time accumulated aify this version of
you you thought you were for something
to come in and just smash it to pieces
in the space of no time at all just
toally Ah that's great I uh I I I spoke
with this author recently whose first
book was a mega Blockbuster success and
his second book was by any objective
standards a huge success but in order of
magnitude or two less lower than his
first book [__] and totally [__] and I
asked him how that felt and he said uh
even though he knew that was GNA be the
case going into his second book he knew
that would be the case and he was
prepared for this it hurt it hurt
because his first book set the bar so
ridiculously high have you got this in
your mind given that the psychology of
money your first book was ju I mean you
you're telling me that it's it's growing
it's like the AR not number of your book
is like Co on a bad day uh yeah
have you got it that same as ever
despite the fact that everyone needs to
go and buy it right now and the link is
in the description below is almost
certainly going to be a disappointment
to you yeah I I I think about it a lot
and that was one of the points of
talking to that author who I was
speaking with because I I know this is
going to be my situation of yeah how do
you prepare mentally when I I hope to
write many books in my career and I
would bet very good money that the first
book I wrote will by an order of
magnitude be the biggest seller it's
kind of it's kind of a hard thing to to
wrap your head of course it's a good
problem to have nobody feels bad for you
but yeah it is kind of a hard thing like
when I'm 66 how am I going to feel
knowing that I peaked at age 36 when
psychology money came out it's probably
not going to feel that great to be
honest but it's of all the problems to
have it's it's not a bad one yeah uh
have you seen the lwis Capaldi
documentary no do you know who lisis
Capaldi is Scottish singer Guy you would
have heard his song 100% one of your
kids will have had his song on it at
some know you'll have heard it on the
radio billions and billions and billions
of streams and albums and all this stuff
documentary about him and he has to
write a second album first album's just
ridiculous success right Globe trotting
insanity and it's songs that he wrote
when he was 17 still playing them in
working men's pubs around Scotland right
and it's better mastering and Studios
and all the rest of it but it's the same
songs and then he gets this catapulted
to the top of the tree and then is told
right do it again and Co happens so he's
back in his parents' house in Scotland
in this uh shed type thing that's got
his recording equipment in there trying
to write songs for this second album and
he develops a twitch like a Tourette's
twitch um and it's there's videos you
can look at the videos it's pretty
uncomfortable to watch of him at
glastenbury Big festivals and he can't
sing like he literally can't get the
words out because of how nervous he is
so he's yeah very much feeling the
pressure a man who has the tent but not
the Constitution to be famous which I
think is a beautiful very interesting
dichotomy um and he's got this one line
in it that I paused the documentary and
just turned it off after that and went
into like a fever dream for about an
hour thinking about it he's there and
he's talking about all of this change
and there's been all of this chaos
around him and he's trying to write the
second album and the pressure from the
label and all of this sort of stuff and
he turned to the camera and he goes Fame
doesn't change you it just changes
everybody around you yeah yeah oh my God
every time I say it dude I get my the
hairs on my arms stand up because I just
thought it was so profound and so
beautiful and uh yeah yeah you should
watch it it's on Netflix it's kind of
scary because what do so many people
even if not explicitly but they
implicitly hope for and want in life it
it rounds to fame at least if not
explicitly Fame is what they want and
then you watch these people who've
actually had it and there's a lot of
baggage attached to it and I I really
admire the people who went out of their
way to push back or to quit the system
one is the actress Cameron Diaz Mega
A-list actress and then she said she's
done she's she's done acting now she's
still famous I'm sure the paparazzi
still Hound her and whatnot she she
can't get rid of that but for people who
say I've had enough I achieved what I
wanted to in this industry and I'm and
and I'm out of here the other example I
don't know how to pronounce this band's
name it was spelled g y te and they had
one Mega hit in 2012 I I I don't know
how to pronounce It Go [__] what whatever
it is sounds like go yeah I think that's
what it is and they have this mega mega
Blockbuster hit in 2012 it's all over
the world it's like the top song and
then they just quit they said we're done
like we're never going to top that we're
out of here we're and I have so much
respect for that if you can actually
pull it off it's the people who feel
like they start with a mega Blockbuster
and then they have to top it the next
time that you are you're guaranteeing
yourself depression and misery if if
that's your goal you had this other bit
saying expectations are easy to ignore
because their value isn't on a price tag
what's that no we what we know what is
the cost of a Ferrari you can look at
the price thing you know what the cost
is it's very easy to measure and put on
a spreadsheet and get with Precision
this is the cost of a Ferrari not only
is this a cost but here's how much work
you have to do to earn that much money
so it's very it's very quantifiable but
what is the cost of high expectations
most people are completely oblivious to
them and you can't really measure them
with a lot of precision but they are
enormous cost because they're Weighing
on your happiness and so that's that's
really what it is and that's why they're
so easy to ignore it's because they're
not on a price tag it's not quantifiable
how do I say like how do I quantify the
fact that I have higher expectations for
medical care than johy Rockefeller did
how do you quantify that you can but
it's very real it's extremely
real yeah I I've got another one for you
dude so me and George Mack have been
working on this for a while hidden and
observable metrics and and it's our
contention that people trade hidden
metrics for observable metrics and it's
mostly to do with the gamification the
ability to track it's like how visceral
and how front of mind it is but a good
example of hidden metric would be the
quality of the relationship with your
significant other or uh time is an odd
metric it's kind of hidden it's kind of
not Peace of Mind sanity right quality
of sleep uh your ability to spend your
attention where you want it to be as
opposed to it being distracted all of
these things right happily traded for a
raise happily traded to change to a
different job which is twice the
distance away one of the biggest
determinants in someone's life happiness
is the length of their commute right I
learned that from Jonathan height like
if you want to be happier half your
commute don't worry about the wage and
uh yeah people will happily well I'm
going to spend an extra you know 45
minutes there 45 minutes back which
means an hour and a half that I'm not
going to spend with my wife and that's
going to cause this amount of
degradation of the amount of
relationship satisfaction that we get
but 20 grand extra a year or whatever
right hidden metric traded for an
observable metric and and the fact that
you can measure your salary down to the
penny and not only that but I can
compare mine to yours so if if we're in
a society where it doesn't matter what I
have as long as I have more than you I
can measure that so cleanly but what
also matters to your life success in
terms of the quality of your marriage
your ability to be a good parent your
own happiness to sleep eight hours at
night with a clear conscience you those
things are very hard to quantify if not
impossible to quantify but they matter
more so I think it's I I think all of
that observable versus unobservable it's
that that's what it is it's just we're
searching for something that's so easy
to quantify everything else even if it
matters more it's out of sight out of
mind George is trying to battle back
against this by making the hidden
observable so he's got some type form
thing that populates a Google sheet it's
Peak autism and he puts in at the end of
the day how many stars he was did he
wake up at this time did he do these
things and tries to track correlations
and basically tries to bring the hidden
into the observable realm so he's forced
to quantify uh that which is usually
just kind of like an ephemeral
wishy-washy notion it's like this
ambient [__] sense behind the back of
his head um so to kind of round this out
and I think it's a really really
important point I'm so glad that you put
it in the
book presumably there are two things
that you can change right either your
expectations or your circumstances you
can either reduce your expectations down
or you can raise the quality of your
life up on whatever metric it is that
you're playing about with tactically
have you found any way to reduce your
expectations the only the only thing
that's worked for me I wrote about this
in the psychology money was this it was
an observation that I had when I was a
valet at a festar hotel in Los Angeles
during college and there would be all
these people driving in in rolls-royce's
Bentley's Lamborghinis and I realized I
was like 20 at the time but I realized
that never once when somebody drove in
in a Lambo did I look at the driver and
say oh that guy is so cool what I did is
I imagined myself as a driver and I
thought if I was a driver people would
be looking at me and thinking that I'm
cool but it was like wait but I never do
that for the D I just imagined myself so
then it was nobody actually cares about
the driver but they want to be the
driver because they think people will
then care about them and it was just
like once you recognize that game and
the big takeaway is like nobody is
thinking about you as much as you are
they're busy thinking about themselves
and once you realize that no one's
paying any attention to the size of your
house or how nice your car is nobody's
paying attention to your clothes nobody
is paying attention to him as much as
you are once you recognize that then I
think your uh desire to put out your
peacock feathers like that diminishes
not not to zero it's not to say you
should look like a slop it's not that in
the slightest it's just when you realize
that nobody nobody cares about your your
circumstances as much as you do because
they're busy worrying about themselves
then I think it's much easier to keep
your expectations in check and be like
why do I want to spend money on this
thing that's going to make me look
better when nobody's even paying
attention to it except maybe the people
who who are like very close in my life
my spouse my kids my parents who don't
care about the clothes that I'm wearing
they love me for being me so that's like
that realization for me was like okay
look I like nice homes and nice cars but
when you recognize that game I think
your ambition for those just peacock
feathered aspects of life goes way down
wild Minds people who think about the
world in unique ways you like also think
about the world in unique ways you won't
like I started thinking about this years
ago when people were like Elon Musk is
kind of rude on Twitter and he's saying
the wrong things and he's not very
polite to people and like of course this
is a guy who at age 30 took on GM Ford
and NASA at the same time and succeeded
like of course he's not a well-balanced
individual of course he has these crazy
quirks and of course he thinks that the
rules of society don't apply to him
because that's what you like him for the
reason that people like and admire Elon
Musk is because he doesn't think any of
the rules apply to him and he's willing
to take these Bonkers bets on new
technologies and new engineering and
with that an unavoidable part an undiv
visible part of that are these are these
parts of the world where he thinks about
the world differently than you in
negative ways and he can be a j he has
different political views than people
and you cannot separate those two you
cannot have somebody who is a crazy out
of boox thinker in a positive way and
also dresses and speaks and looks and is
polite like an average citizen it does
not exist every person who has outside
success is going to have some traits in
them that are bad even if someone like
Warren Buffett he like the the best
investor of all time came at the expense
of time with his family and his kids
like there's always most people I heard
this quote the other day everybody adds
up to the same number but there's like
different ways to get there and I think
most people who are abnormally good at
one thing are almost always abnormally
bad at something else like it's like
those numbers are going to even out in
the end so if you take somebody like
musk who is like off the charts talented
at engineering and risk-taking
Entrepreneurship
of course he's going to have traits in
which he is abnormally bad in equal
parts to what he is good at and I think
there are so few exceptions to that
actually think the closest that we've
come to an a crazy thinker who looked
and acted like a normal CEO is Bill
Gates there there there aren't many
others who are like that where it's like
he was this crazy hard driving Visionary
but he wore a suit and said the right
things on conference calls there aren't
many people like that uh even if you
looked at Mark Zuckerberg like he was
one of the first who was just like I'm
I'm G to wear t-shirts and jeans and
even that little thing was just like
like he he didn't look the part of what
he was supposed to be doing because he's
just like I'm gonna do it my own way on
my own person so for all of these people
there are traits and and to me it's just
a like be careful who you look up to
because you cannot pick and choose the
parts of people that you look up to so
you can't say this came from nval you
can't say I want his body and his mind
and his wealth you got it all comes with
the same package so so if you look up to
this person and say I want to be like
that guy well you got to take the full
package the good and the bad they always
come one and the same that Naval
sequence has inspired like probably 10
blog posts from me there's another one
from Jason pain which is great except
that all of your heroes are full of [__]
Your Heroes aren't Gods they're just
regular people who probably got good at
One Thing by neglecting literally
everything else so you know Tiger Woods
goat golfer not a fantastic husband Alan
Watts life-changing spiritual teacher
died of alcoholism early James Joyce guy
that wrote finegan awaken ulyses
masterful author but also posthumously a
bunch of fart fetish love letters that
he wrote to his wife got released like
you know you might want to be the best
golfer on the planet but do you want to
be chased down the driveway by your wife
wielding a club that presumably you got
for free from your sponsor like you
might want to have millions of people
fall asleep to the things that you say
in this beautiful British accent but do
you want to die early
because of how much you drink or like
you might want to write Blockbuster
novels like ulyses and fegan's wake do
you want to have your innermost thoughts
about the different types of farts that
come out of your wife while you have
anal sex with her be released to the
world upon your death probably not no
yeah I guess you I I I imagine that you
would say no I I read a lot of
biographies of entrepreneurs and
Generals and presid never once not a
single time have I finished a biography
of someone who achieved these Heights in
life and said or thought I wish I could
have lived that life and and the
opposite is almost always true it's
usually at the end of the book it's like
you achieved a lot but that was that was
a insane life that I
never within a 100 miles of it I just
finished the Ken Burns documentary on uh
Ernest Hemingway and here's another he
was the author of the century I don't
think that's an exaggeration and his
personal life was the most despicable
miserable
immoral uh drunken life that you can
imagine and of course he ended by taking
his own life and but the the finer
details of what his day-to-day life were
like nobody would look at that and say
that looks fun it was it was easy to
glamorize the life of a writer this big
macho guy who loved bull fights but like
the actual of like his love life his
family life his alcoholism his
depression was terrible it was awful and
I also don't think that you can
detach how good he was of a writer from
that alcoholic depression it's driven
the it was driven by that and it was it
was that messed up mind it was that pain
in his head that created the good
writing that we all
enjoy what does it say that the people
who we most ad admire are the ones who
have the least admirable internal
States I think that that was kind of the
point of of this chapter it's like be
careful who you look up to and after
that I started trying to admire people
in my life who I thought lived a good
life but we're like I mean this in the
most polite way like very average very
like not not the celebrity not the
billionaire entrepreneur but who do I
know who is just like oh that that guy
is a good husband and a good dad and
he's in good shape he takes care of
himself he takes care of his family he's
smart he's educated he's funny and look
he doesn't make that much money nobody
knows who he is but let's leave that
aside the rest of his life looks amazing
and it's something that I want for
myself I want to be a good husband I
want to be a good dad I want to take
could care of myself so like rather than
looking up to the famous celebrity look
up to the guy across the street who
nobody knows like that's actually who's
closer to be your Your Role Model yeah
the same personality traits that push
people to the top also increase the odds
of pushing them over the edge and I
found out that we're both Mutual fans of
John Boyd who if you want to talk about
extreme personalities that achieved
stuff this is a guy who actually wrote
the book on fighter pilots for the US
Air Force during a kind of a glory
period right sort of 40s through to 80s
which is kind of like this era of of
fighter pilots and he would smoke cigars
I think once there was a story that he
just put his cigar out on one of his
commanders ties he just he he was he was
an absolute monster there was some story
I may be getting some of these details
wrong but there was a story of he was in
the barracks with his with his his
fellow air forcen and the the heater
wasn't good enough it was in the middle
of the winter and they were all cold and
the army refused to put in new heaters
so he burned the barracks down he lit
them on fire and burned them just at a
protest and there's there's all these
scenes of like these little things of he
would be in a meeting with his superiors
with generals and he would be he would
like bite the callus off his hands and
spit it across the table just like he
was just a monster of a human but he was
so talented at being a fighter pilot and
he was so good at figuring out the math
of the certain speeds and the
trajectories of how you wanted your
plane but with that ridiculous Talent
came the personality that was like
impossible for people to put up with
wild numbers people don't want accuracy
they want
certainty there's there's this great
quote where Jerry Seinfeld and and Jimmy
Kimmel are driving in a car and it's
this old car it's like this old relic of
a car this like this this old custom car
and Jimmy Kimmel gets in and he said he
says there's no seat belts in here does
that bother you and Jerry sefel says no
but tell me the truth how often in your
life have you actually needed a seat
belt and like it's a joke it's supposed
to be funny but in that is like the
world is governed by odds it's not black
and white it's like if it like of course
if there is a one 1,000 of a percent
chance that you're going to need the
seat belt in your life you should wear
it every day people understand that but
what actually gets people like to pay
attention in life is just whether you
are right or wrong and you see this a
lot in investing where it's like I think
there's an 80% chance that this stock is
going to go down but then if if it goes
up was I was I wrong like no like I I I
this is not a black or white thing this
happened in a big way during the 2016
presidential election when Nate silver
who is a very famous statistician who
predicts elections he said that the odds
were that Hillary Clinton was going to
win and I think at the time he said
there's a 70% chance or 80% chance that
Hillary Clinton's gonna win obviously
she did not win and so the next morning
every headline was Nate silver was wrong
Nate silver got this wrong Nate silver
blew his forecast and he was like no I
said there's an 80% chance he's going to
win which implies there's a 20% chance
that Trump is going to win just because
that's what happened doesn't mean it was
wrong but most people will not accept
that form of thinking it's black or
white were you right or were you wrong
and so that's like it's a big flaw when
people think about numbers in the world
and data and statistics is that the
world is governed by probabilities but
everybody thinks in just binary yes or
no right or wrong and it makes it so
it's really difficult to know who to pay
attention to like you want to be paying
attention to the Nate overs who think
about the world and probabilities and
even when they are quote unquote wrong
it's like it's actually really tough to
tell whether that was like a bad call um
like he easily could have been right
like there was an 80% chance Hillary was
going to win that was probably the right
statistic even if it didn't turn out to
be how it like what happened in the real
world so the way that people think about
numbers is is like screwed up in all
kinds of ways and it just makes it
that's part of the reason that we're so
bad at predicting markets and politics
is like the world is governed by
probabilities but we always think binary
right or wrong I think there's something
seductive about a person who is able to
speak in binaries and black and white as
well because it seems like certainty
which is a good proxy for expertise and
you don't actually know like if if
everyone's just throwing [__] at the
wall and my shit's sexier than your [__]
even if my shit's wrong it's going to
Garner more attention right I I I see
this online with you know other cultural
commentators and and people that do
YouTube and podcasts and stuff I'm very
un I'm chronically uncertain of
everything about and it's why I don't
really make big proclamations about much
that I don't have an area of expertise
in didn't bother commenting on coid
didn't bother commenting on Ukraine
didn't bother commenting on Israel
because I don't think that the world
needs more noise it needs more signal
and uneducated idiots like me who don't
have specific knowledge within that
domain giving Cod psychology opinions
about it is precisely the problem that
we're trying to battle back against
that's exactly you you you had a post on
Twitter recently that was just about
this for what's going on in Israel where
you said I I I don't I don't know enough
to comment on the situation and I know
there were a lot of people who took
issue with that well how how can you not
know more about this situation that you
don't know more about I I don't know it
it it is what it is but I think yeah the
the world would be a much better place
if uh people that didn't know what they
were talking about tried to not talk
about the things they don't know about
and we all get out over Asis right you
know that same thing I spoke about
earlier on like if you if you're someone
who has a young medium or old age
garnered a little bit of attention like
why shouldn't I why shouldn't I give my
thoughts on epidemiology why shouldn't I
give my thoughts on the lab leak
hypothesis why why why don't they want
to know about my my my opinions on
immigration you know they're very very
interesting when it comes to
productivity or Focus or whatever the
hell else it is that you talk about and
you
think again with that there's um
seductiveness to uh fluency in
particular uh but absolutely certainty
too uh there's this guy called Peter
Zion real interesting guy geopolitics
dude um and I I don't know enough to be
able to stress test his ideas uh but I
know one thing he's one of the most
certain humans when it comes to speaking
that I have ever heard and he came on
the show and I found him very compelling
but I don't know much about what am we
going to do go dig into the [__]
demography of of China and be like oh
actually I I think it's not going to be
650 million it's going to be 750 like
I'm not going to go do that right but
right there I remember uh thinking at
the time while speaking to him and I've
kept in touch with him I think he's a
very interesting dude uh wow like this
guy speaks with so much certainty and he
has vehement fans on the internet and I
think it goes right back to what we said
at the very beginning which is people
abhor a vacuum and they abhor
uncertainty and if you can give them
something that seems like order wrangled
out of Chaos
oh you you're I allow me to become an
evangelist like you know I will pray at
the altar of the person who can tell me
what's going to happen I me this is this
is Cults how many [__] Cults are like
the world's going to end on the 21st of
December 2012 or whatever it is and then
it doesn't happen but the certainty was
so much there that the seduction
continues even when the certainty was
proven to be wrong even when they're
wrong because what people actually want
they don't want the truth they don't
even want an accurate forecast they want
to reduce the uncertainty that exists in
their head at this moment today and so
even when the pundit is wrong people
don't care because the pundit already
did its job of reducing uncertainty when
they went on TV last week and so that's
a yeah that's a that that's a big part
of this if you go on TV and you say
there's a 20% chance of a recession next
year that will be your last time on TV
but if you say 100% chance and it's
going to be bad and it's going to affect
these people in these industries your
phone will ring off the hook because
you've just reduced uncertainty even if
what you are professing is something
that's pessimistic and is scary if you
say it with certainty people are like
that's who I want to pay attention to I
think a lot of religions are probably
like this too like like most religions
don't say there's a 20% chance that
heaven exists it's it's it's it's this
is exactly what's gonna happen with 100%
certainty and there's no wiggle room the
Church of hous i' I'd attend that that's
right and but but that it reduces
uncertainty when you know for certain
exactly how the world works and what's
going to happen in in the future what's
going to happen in the afterlife there's
a very comforting aspect to that that
removes uncertainty that is so
unpleasant to deal with in your head
what is it about the sufficiently big
sample size playing out thing that you
talk about one of the things that's
always struck me is that since the end
of World War II when we've had pretty
good economic data of like we track the
economy with a lot of precision there
have been I think nine recessions which
is not that many like the sample size
that we're dealing with right now is is
is ridiculous small and if you wanted to
really be an expert on economic history
you would if if if you had like a wish
from the genie you would say give me a
100,000 years of Apple's to Apple's data
that that I can study the economy like
let me study the last 10,000 recessions
but of course we don't have that we have
good data on nine of them all that were
each that was caused by like a very
specific thing so it's we really don't
for something as fundamental like an
important for society as recessions and
economic growth the truth is we really
don't know that much we don't know what
a really bad recession looks like we
don't know the peak of our of our
potential or like how fast the economy
can grow our sample size is so limited
but since it's all we have and because
it's still 80 years worth of data it
seems like a long period of time it's
very tempting to say the average
recession lasts for eight months or
whatever it is it's very tempting to say
the average recession unemployment goes
to 8% but when you look at that average
what that average is like there is so
much else that could happen for good or
bad like the economy being way stronger
than we think it could be or way worse
than we think it could be once we
realize that the data that we're looking
at of economic history is so
limited you talk about unfortunate odds
and recklessness and kind of
distinguishing between the two I think
uh
retroactively even if we can see what
occurred in the past it's so hard to try
and work out the correlation okay was
did these two things just happen
together or did this thing actually
cause this thing to happen was it
unfortunate odds was it recklessness it
it makes this entire situation really
messy you know the the one I think about
a lot is that uh in 2007 I think it was
Mark Zuckerberg was offered a billion
dollars for Facebook and he of course
turned it down and we look at that we're
like what a freaking genius he was
because now the company's worth a
trillion dollars or whatever like one of
the smartest decisions that you could
ever make uh but during that same time
Yahoo was offered $50 billion for
Microsoft that Microsoft wanted to buy
yaho and Yahoo turned it down and we
look at that and we're like you idiots
like they of course you should have
taken it because now I don't know what
Yahoo is worth but it's not within 20
miles of $50 billion doar and so you
look at that and it's like well how do
we know Mark Zuckerberg made a great
decision and Yahoo didn't like like
there's such an easy world to imagine in
which Facebook was a flash in the pan
and Yahoo became the next Google you
could easily imagine that world it
didn't happen but it easily could have
happened so when we look at these
retroactive decisions and say uh these
retrospective decisions and say look
Mark Zuckerberg was so smart and yaho
was so stupid it's not that clear even
if that's what actually happened in
there all these alternative histories
that not only could have but should have
happened that could could have made that
narrative so much different than it is
everyone's post talk rationalizing
everything all the time the more that
I've dug into personal growth and and
development
and being around successful people the
vast majority of what people are doing
is I have found a particular strategy
that resulted in success for
me given my idiosyncrasies and path of
lease resistance and genetic
predisposition and upbringing and
culture and timing and gender and all of
that stuff let me now create universal
laws for everybody that is a
retrospective justification of how what
I did that gave me success is something
anyone can do that can give anyone
success when like the irony is like the
reason that you are successful is
because it only worked for you if that
could work for everybody everybody would
do it and that skill wouldn't matter at
all anymore like the whole reason that
this person got successful is because
nobody else could do that thing that
they're now trying to turn into a
universal law so I think there are some
things that we can learn from these
these major successes like if you're
looking at Warren Buffett the the traits
that you want to learn from is like his
p
his endurance but I I don't think you
should learn his stocks picking skills
because so many of those skills were
honed in 1950 when this Market was
completely different than it is today so
that's why you know one of the most
famous investing books is the
intelligent investor by Benjamin Graham
and it was first written in the 1930s
and there is of course a lot of Timeless
wisdom in there but there's also a lot
in those books that is like hypers
specific to the economy in the 1930s in
the 1940s that if you tried to implement
those form foras today you'd lose
everything it was it was just relevant
to that period of time and it's not
something that you can scale into a
universal law best story wins stories
are always more powerful than statistics
why it drives you crazy if you think the
world is going to be governed by the
right answer and the best answer and if
I can just come up with the right answer
like that's what's going to change
people's minds and it's almost never the
case it's always the case that what
actually like gets people to nod their
heads it's just whoever's telling the
best story the most compelling story and
even if if the person is like that's not
to say that they're fooling people but
if if you have the right answer and
you're not a good Storyteller you may or
may not get ahead but if you have the
right answer and you're a good
Storyteller sky's the limit like those
are the people that really run with it
it's so easy to Discount the power of a
good story because it's a soft skill
like a lot of analytically minded people
think if I can just find the right
answer in the spreadsheet if I can just
create the the product that works the
best everything else will take care of
itself and it's just not how it works we
were talking earlier I write about this
in the book Ken Burns who I think is
just absolute genius documentary
filmmaker and everything he's ever made
is just 10 out of 10 it's so good and
one of the things he does so well is
incorporating music into his
documentaries and he's talked about this
before where he will literally change
the sentence structure of a script so
that a specific word that the narrator
is saying matches with a specific beat
in the background music the emotional
word matches the emotional beat at the
same time and no other filmmaker no
other historian is doing that most
historians are just say if I have the if
I find the right information in the in
the library like that's that's that's
what I'm going to present and Ken Burns
is like no this is going to be a
performance and because of that I I I
make this point that almost nothing Ken
Burns has ever published is new
information he writes about or he's made
films on the Civil War and World War III
and the Holocaust these are very heavily
studied events everybody knows everyone
knows how the story ends but his magic
is that he's the best Storyteller that
exists of any historian who's ever
existed and because of that when the
Civil War documentary came out in 1990
kenburn Civil War documentary more
Americans watched it that year than
watched the Super Bowl and this isn't
about this is about an event the Civil
War that everyone has been reading about
since grade school there's no new
information in the docu
but the storytelling is so captivating
that it it moves mountains I think this
is true for Michael Lewis too of there
there's there's been No Better Business
Storyteller in modern times and look
with some of what's come out recently
like he doesn't necessarily always get
the story right per se it's it could be
easy to criticize him but e maybe this
is just because I'm a writer I I just
finished going infinite the book about
FTX and even if yes there are Parts like
many other people where I thought he was
being unfair and supporting SPF in ways
that I didn't agree with but his
storytelling is so good his sentence
structure is so good his writing is so
poetic that I will read it all day long
no matter what it comes out with like
the best story is always going to win I
feel like that when I read yours man I
adore the Simplicity of your sentences
whether it's on your blog collaborative
fund and there's a newsletter that I
subscribe to I I want to say sorry to
whoever else writes for you because my
first thing is I click if it's not got
Morgan housel written at the top I just
ignore it and the only ones I read I'm
sure the rest of the Writ is really
great but I just focus on you um yeah
the Simplicity of your sentences even
some I guess you would you break
convention in in your books especially
in the new one uh single lines three or
four word lines that are paragraphs all
on their own that was that was very
intentional and the and the Publishers
don't don't like it but that's how I
like to read and I think it's I think
what a lot of readers really want out of
a book or what really makes them feel
good is making progress they're like oh
I finished this chapter I finished this
level moving on to the next and when you
have when you turn a page and it is
solid uninterrupted block of texts it's
very easy to be like oh God like what do
I got in front of me not today Satan but
when it's quick when it's a quick line
it's just boom boom boom it's much
easier to a feel like you're making
progress but also it's just an easier
format to read it you can just kind of
Breeze your eyes over the page and soak
it up rather than like really dense
powerful reading so yeah I think that
structure is it's part of it and I yeah
you're right I don't think most readers
think about the length of their
structures or the the the the visibility
of what a paragraph actually looks like
like like like a block of text but it's
critically important to the the reading
experience yeah your books have a a
particular uh robustness to put Dow
inness like it's very difficult to put
them down for precisely that reason
there's a little bit more there's
another little thing oh there's a story
about [__] World War II like let me
get into that and yeah for my newsletter
I stole a bunch of ideas um yourself
James Clear uh Ryan holiday even some of
the con conventions that he uses and um
the newsletter this is kind of common
commonly done now but it's one sentence
per paragraph with smaller line breaks
in between and it's just straight
through super easy very nice to read
tight margins so yeah like stuff like
that and we were talking before we
started about the um story that I try
and tell with these big Productions that
I do on the show you know I want to we
choose the location of these
particular uh venues based on the guest
that we're speaking to so you know we
have Patrick B David coming on and he's
kind of like a like a a power guy like a
power broker kind of guy he's like a
Mafia Boss so I wanted a wall of bugs
right or we we have uh an Andrew hubman
coming on who's kind of this interesting
blend of sort of science and precision
with kind of like raw masculine kind of
like grittiness like in terms of the way
that he presents so he found this um
beautiful Warehouse with exposed wooden
beams uh so it's kind of got that
rawness to it but it's organic as well
and it feels it sort of humanizes it or
we do Peterson and we did him in in the
Alamo in San Antonio and it's got this
sort of beautifully ornate um uh blinds
behind him this sort of wooden blinds
it's casting this very particular kind
of light through so you know we're
trying to do something to just create
this little bit more uh of an event of
an occasion but you're totally right
that you know many of us me
included how many times have we felt
resentment for somebody who we think has
achieved success that they don't deserve
because of the way that they look or
because of something which is outside of
the substance of what they're doing you
know all Style no substance is a meme
for a reason and you know with Ken Burns
you could spend forever designing the
sentences to hit the beat of the the
music and do all the rest of the stuff
but ultimately the reason that it works
is because of the story yeah that is
then packaged in the way that's
appropriate and going back to what we
were saying before about certainty
fluency is another thing you know if
you've got some beautifully fluent
person you got this great story uh about
Martin Luther King right if you have
someone who's unbelievably fluent not
forgetting that he went off script in
his famous I Have a Dream speech and he
he gives himself a pattern break right
he starts doing it follows the script
goes ah no and then freestyles it like
that's it the the fluency literally
outdid the rational
prescribed wellth thought out arithmetic
stuff The Good the the script that he
and his speech writer wrote that day is
what he started to speak from and then
there was a gospel singer in the crowd a
couple lines in front of him who was a
friend of of Martin Luther King and you
could actually hear this in some of the
videos at one point in in the speech she
she turns around and she says tell him
about the dream Martin tell him about
the dream and you can literally see this
in the video at that point he takes his
script on the podium and he moves it to
the side and then he looks up to the sky
and he starts saying I have a dream and
then the rest is history and he had
actually practiced that I have a dream
it was another speech that he had given
before but in the moment I think he
could dis sense that the speech that he
was prepared to give was not the best
one that day and that the gospel singer
malalia Jackson was was was right that
the I have a dream was the one he should
have been doing and he just started
freewheeling it and became literally the
most famous speech of modern history how
are stories like Leverage when you've
got a complex
topic it's it's like Leverage because
you can squeeze more value out of them
than you could just get by just putting
raw data on the table so I mean you can
you know if I think I think a lot of
entrepreneurs will think if I have a
successful company I need to come up
with something brand new like the
reinvent the wheel kind of thing and a
lot of times you don't you can take a
pre-existing product and just tell a
better story with it like boom you're
Off to the Races that's great and so
there's once you realize how much
leverage you can get out of a story or
and how powerful a story can be like the
the field of opportunities in front of
you is endless because you don't need to
come up with something brand new Ken
Burns is is the 10,000th person to
document World War II but he did the
best job of ad because he he told a
story if Ken Burns had to find new
history find a new event that never
heard of for his things like forget
about it there you can't do that but if
you can use a good story to leverage
what's already out there you can become
the most famous Storyteller of your era
what's the complex bit how why is it
when a topic is complex stories are like
Leverage do they help to synthesize down
confusion yeah I mean I mean most
people's tolerance for complexity is so
limited and everyone knows like the dull
Professor who just talks in P values and
is just like writes in charts and is so
like monotonous
and if you can switch that out with a
good Storyteller like Off to the Races
like there there's so much you can do
out there so it's particularly in the
complicated topics that are boring and
dry and dull this is why Richard fean
was such a genius he took physics which
is so boring and so dull for most people
but he could tell a story about it
there's this video online you should
people should search for it it's he's
explaining the physics of fire of like
like how does fire actually work and I
I'm not going to do it anywhere near the
justice but he's like imagine a
trampoline with two bowling balls on it
and they're both like competing for
space and they're running into each
other and when they run into each other
like they move around and he's
describing how molecules interact with
each other that creates fire and I I
didn't I I didn't do the the the
accurate job there but when he does it
you're like oh that's so entertaining
and by the way I understand the physics
of fire now in a way that if I had just
pulled out a physics textbook I would
have been like this is so I a I don't
understand it and even if I understand
it this is so boring to
read yeah I like that
again the best diet is the one you stick
to the best fitness plan is the one that
you follow the best habit is the one
that you're compliant with ultimately in
order to be able to get whatever the
information is that you want across you
need to play the
game using the rules and the rules
include all of the lack of attention and
boredom and ease of distraction and
everything else that humans have Eric
Weinstein said this to me about um in a
stickiness arms race most sticky message
is the one that wins not necessarily the
one which is most accurate and you know
this is how cultural memes take hold
like I have a friend Mary who says meme
first explain later which is why coming
up with a name for something a great
name oh will retrofit the idea to the
[__] name like get the name uh
because presuming like if the idea is
bollocks it doesn't
matter it's the packaging in many
regards and I think the storytelling
side but you know I still see inside of
me that oh this almost like a a a purity
like a a puritanism to like this is the
way that it should be done it should be
you shouldn't need to dress up the facts
it should just be the the the raw data
and the fact that it's truthful and
honest blah blah blah it's like no dude
like this things got to be sexy Victoria
Secrets they even they are rolling back
their change in branding from the last
couple of years they're pivoting back
towards sexiness so very very famous
example from from Steve Jobs with the
iPod where you could have called it
digital MP3 player but instead what
Steve Jobs said was a thousand songs in
your pocket that's just a story and like
for the people who are just like we
don't need to dress up the technology it
should it should exist on its own they
would have called it digital MP3 player
which is probably what Sony and
Panasonic did and Steve Jobs said a
thousand songs in your pocket which
everyone can instantly be like oh that
sounds great I love it that that's what
I want it was just such a brilliant era
of Storytelling does not compute the
world is driven by forces that cannot be
measured there's so many examples when
you're watching a group of people or an
individual do something and you're like
why are you doing that makes no sense
whatsoever you should have quit long ago
you shouldn't be doing it but they keep
doing it and if you expect that every
person is a rational thinker and they're
doing things that make sense that add up
on the spreadsheet you're going to go
through life completely Bamboozled at
the number of people who don't and so I
use this example in that chapter of
during at the end of World War II the
battle of the bulge when the Nazis
attacked the Allies there was a big they
made a big counter offensive it was a
complete surprise to the Allies they
really never saw it coming which is why
the the battle was such a big deal and
the reason they saw it coming is because
the US generals the the Allied generals
thought there is no rational World in
which the Germans would Counterattack
right now they don't have enough troops
they don't have enough supplies they
don't have enough fuel the weather is
atrocious the geography is not in their
favor so therefore we assume they're not
going to counterattacked what they they
missed was that the Germans were not
rational thinkers at the time Hitler was
not a rational thinker he was completely
out of his mind and so because because
the the Allied generals assumed that
their opponent was rational they they
they missed what actually happened
that's why they were so vulnerable so
going through life assuming it's the
same with market bubbles if you assume
that people are rational with their
money like of course they're not then
you're going to be completely Bamboozled
when once a decade there's a massive
bubble and people light their money on
fire and you can't figure out what's
going on what's going on is like things
just don't compute there's a human
element like the world is not governed
by spreadsheets there's an emotional
hormonal human element that's very hard
to track impossible to measure but has
some of the biggest outcomes in any of
these activities in life who's archal
hill archal hill was this crazy he was
he's such a cool guy he was a
physiologist about a hundred years ago
uh and he was a big Runner he was he was
an athlete and because he was a
physiologist and an athlete he devoted a
lot of his career to just trying to
answer the question how fast can people
run given like given my body given my
aerobic capacity or given your body
what's the theoretical theoretical limit
on how fast we can run and he came up
with all of these formulas he was kind
of the early for uh uh guy who came up
with V2 Max which which a lot of people
are familiar with now to really measure
like how people process oxygen how it's
dispersed throughout your body the
lactic acid build up in your legs and it
came up with a formula for how fast
people can run and it was very accurate
so people like these athletes would come
into his laboratory and he'd run his
tests and he would say you know making
this up he'd say Jim the fastest you can
run a mile is six minutes and 32 seconds
and Jim would go out on the track and
give it all he's got and he'd run it in
six minutes and 32 seconds like this
formula was very accurate and heill
actually won the Nobel Prize in medicine
I think in 1922 but there was this Quirk
about it in that his formula was never
able to predict a race winner like in a
competitive race you could not use this
formula and predict who is going to win
the Olympic gold medal in track and I
think this this kind of bothered it
bothered a lot of people in the field
and bothered him as well that this
formula was so accurate on the on the
track on the test track and had no
accuracy in the real world and they
eventually figured out what was going on
here which is that in a competitive race
like the Olympics when the stakes are
very high people get nervous they get
excited they get rushes of adrenaline
they get all these other emotions that
cannot be replicated on the test track
when the stakes are low that completely
Alters your performance and therefore
like his whole takeaway
was your aerobic capacity your ability
as a runner is not just about your
machine your body it's your body within
the context of all your in the moment
incentives and the the crazy hormones
and feelings going through your head
it's those two things in combination
that creates your actual capacity so I I
I phrase this too of like if if you said
the fastest you can run a mile is six
minutes and 30 30 seconds and you say
like I gave it everything I've got I
can't do it faster but then if I said
hey if you can do it in 6 minutes and 31
seconds I'll give you a million dollars
you'll figure out a way to do it like
like once the incentives change in the
moment you become a completely different
person um and and so I think that
applies to a lot of things in life and
it's why things don't always compute
it's not just a spreadsheet you have to
figure out what's going through people's
heads so logic has its limits and our
ability to be rational and make
predictions is always going to bounce up
against things
that aren't able to fit inside of the
model always and it drives people crazy
this is just like best story winds where
if you if you assume the world is
governed by Logic you're going to be led
astray your entire life because it never
is whether it's the Germans deciding to
attack when they shouldn't or trying to
predict Athletes Performance I I grew up
as a ski racer that was my sport not a
very popular sport in America but that's
one I follow and the greatest ski racer
now of all time is a woman from the
United States named Michaela shiffrin um
and she she's she's the greatest skier
man or woman in history she's absolute
Beast she's incredible and she has this
thing that she's she's spoken about this
publicly it's not a secret that when the
stakes are very high like in the
Olympics or the World Championships she
Before the Race will vomit and it's it's
a thing she gets so nervous that her
body just you know just kind of gives up
and obviously that has a huge impact on
like your hydration and your energy
levels if you're throwing up before the
races and one of the takeaways is like
Micha shiffrin on the test track on on
when she's training is not the same
skier as she is in the Olympics her
entire mindset is utterly different and
even like the physical composition of
her hydration is completely different
because when the stakes get high and
people start getting nervous and
emotional they become completely
different people so you would think that
her skiing ability would just be like
the strength of her core and her agility
her flexibility and it's not like 90% of
it it's just what's going through her
head in the moment I have a d J friend
who for a long time wanted to be on Eric
PR's label very much idolized him and
then after a decade and a bit of working
and producing and making songs he ended
up doing it and now supports pids all
around the world he's Played Madison
Square Garden New Year's Eve shows with
supporting Eric at his hollow uh
projector thing and uh there was a good
chunk of time where he would throw up
before he went on stage as well and you
know you see him backst and he's just
this super cool guy he's like sort of a
buff like Northeastern British dude and
before he' go up because he cared right
he cared so much about what he was going
to do and you look at you know the
component parts of this particular
person's talent and go ah you know like
they are the function of this and this
and this and this and this and you say
yeah but what about the context and what
about all of the other stuff that you
can't imagine thinking about um the
crazy Battle of the Bulge and the
insanity of Hitler have you ever looked
into to Theodore Morel that was his
personal
physician I've heard a lot about it just
because I know Hitler was drugged out of
his mind particularly in the last years
of his life but I don't know many
details about it dude if you have if you
come across a Theodore Morel um
documentary there's a few of them on
YouTube that are great it's amazing this
guy was a total quack he was injecting
uh Hitler with bull Seaman um he was
like on meth uh injecting him with
cocaine like multiple times per day does
this really
uh interesting interaction between
Hitler and musolini and it's one of
these turning points in the war and I
think that Hitler kind of goes really
really crazy and flies off the handle
and all the rest of it and uh it's
thought that Morel had overdosed him
with some drug so I often think about
you know just how much of what happened
obviously Hitler not internet I'm not
justifying Hitler but I do I do don't
chop this video up know I do sometimes
think about how much of the the madness
that we saw coming out of Nazi Germany
was actually you know due to one
particular quacky
Physician's cupboard and then what he
chose to do to the leader of the Nazi
party and even for regular
run-of-the-mill soldiers it's there's
another thing where it's like it's
impossible to know how you're going to
react and respond until there's bullets
flying over your head there's no amount
of training and preparation that's going
to prepare you for that you you'll know
this isn't there some insane number of
soldiers that went to was it maybe
Vietnam and didn't fire or they were
firing in the air they were purposefully
not firing at the enemy I forget the
exact percentage of it but that was true
in World War II where they could tell
even the soldiers that were in Frontline
combat how many of them actually pointed
their gun at the enemy and pulled the
trigger it's a very low percentage and I
think I I would be willing to bet that a
lot of those people probably knew it
going into it I don't know if I could
kill another human being but I bet there
a lot of it who went in with a lot of
bravado and saying like I'm I'm going
tar training I can do hit the targets in
training and then you see the whites of
the enemy's eyes and you realize it's
just another kid just like you and all
of a sudden you say I don't I don't know
if I could do it and who are you and I
to say that we wouldn't have do the same
thing if you've never been in that
situation you have absolutely no idea
calm plants the seeds of crazy crazy
doesn't mean broken crazy is normal
beyond the point of crazy is normal
it's just this idea that the reason
there is so much volatility in a lot of
things in life particularly the economy
the reason that we have booms and bust
the reason that we have recessions is
because we have periods of calm and when
the economy is calm and people are
really optimistic they once they become
optimistic they go into debt because
they're optimistic about their future of
course I can pay off this debt once they
go into a debt and their optimism grows
the economy becomes unstable once econom
is unstable of course you're going to
have a recession so it's this weird
thing like in in a world in which there
were were no recessions no bare markets
stock market never goes down that is the
world that guarantees the next recession
because think if if if we passed a law
completely hypothetical we pass a law
the stock market cannot go down anymore
the stock market can only go up the
rational thing to do in that situation
would be to mortgage your house and Sell
Your Furniture and buy as many stocks as
you could because they because they're
guaranteed to go up yeah once you do
that the valuations go to the Moon stock
prices get bid up to the stratosphere
and once the valuations are that high
they're guaranteed to crash so this is
like the irony of the reason that you
have Market crashes is because there's
periods of calmness and Comm always
plants the seeds of crazy and it's so
tempting to look at every boom and bust
every bubble every market crash and say
people were crazy like who do we blame
here like who's screwed up and I just
think it's such a natural phenomenon in
in economies there was this economist
back in the 1960s named hman Minsky from
University of St Louis and during the
1960s there was this big idea that we
are going to eradicate recessions that
was a big idea in economic circles and
Minsky basically said it's all [__]
that will never happen and his his
theory was called the financial
instability hypothesis and he laid out
what what I just said if there were no
recessions people would go into debt
because they're optimistic once they go
into debt the economy is unstable once
the economy is unstable you're going to
have a recession so because of that it's
just an like such a clean chain of
events that you can never eradicate
recessions you can't eradicate booms and
busts because calm always plants the
seeds of crazy yeah you've got this idea
about par paranoia leads to success
because it keeps you on your toes and I
guess this is a an
uncomfortable
realization uh that part of the reason
that we are able to survive the chaos of
the world is precisely the emotion that
we are trying to mitigate like our our
paranoia is the competitive Advantage
which is keeping us going it's this
irony of like people are super paranoid
about their career or the business that
they started and if you were to sit them
down on the therapist couch and say why
are you so paranoid they say because
like I have this anxiety and I want to
be successful because once I'm
successful I won't have this anxiety
anymore I need to become rich so I don't
have to worry anymore so they become
super they they they wake up scared
every morning and because of that
because they wake up scared and driven
they're going to become super successful
and then once they get to some level of
success they say now that I've made it I
can relax
because I've made it this was the whole
point of getting rich was so that I
could relax and then once they relax the
thing that made them successful which
was the stress and paranoia is gone and
that's that plants the seeds of their
demise and that you see that with so
many companies like companies that get
fat and happy and lazy and they become
the absolute top of their game and then
they just become they they they they
start to become oblivious and and and
they start to lose it Sears is one of
the best examples of like we don't think
about much today but Sears which is a
department store was the biggest
department store in the United States
similar to Macy's or something like that
and it was the most dominant retailer
that was probably ever existed I think
Sears in its Heyday was more dominant
than than Walmart or Target or anything
like that and now it barely exists it
still technically exists but it's an
absolute shell of its former self and if
you look at the history of ser that's
really what it was it's like a hundred
years ago they were scared and Scrappy
and that's what made them so successful
and then they became so dominant that
they just got lazy and that and that of
course led to their their their fall
same with IBM same with General Motors
same with AIG it's like be careful what
you wish for for that because a lot of
times the reason that you are so
successful is because you have this
trait that you are so eager to get rid
of once you become successful and once
once that happens like boom it's all
over well there's another question kind
of the reverse of this is a question
around if we sacrifice the thing that we
want for the thing which is supposed to
get it what the [__] are we doing like
if we sacrifice happiness in order to be
successful so that when we are finally
successful we can allow ourselves to be
happy if this was an algebra equation
and I just removed success from both
sides of the equation you would just be
left with happiness right it's the
parable of the Mexican fisherman GNA say
the exact same thing but this is that
this is an area where it does not
compute enters the picture because life
isn't an ALG equation if if people just
did the equation what you just said
would make perfect sense and people
would be the Mexican fishermen but it's
it it doesn't compute there's this
element of because from what we were
talking about earlier of like people's
goal is not to become successful it's to
become more successful than other people
yeah so there's never goingon to come a
point where people say oh I'm completely
satisfied I can just sleep in and do
some fishing and hang out with my wife
it's always going to be I have to get to
the next level I have to beat the next
person next to me yeah there's a scene
in Rick and Morty where they play the
game of Roy have you heard of this no
seen this it's it's super legendary on
YouTube it's a one minute long clip you
can watch it it's just Rick and Morty
Roy it'll come up and uh it's a computer
game where you play an imagined life as
this guy and he works as a carpet seller
and uh Morty goes and plays it and he's
a football player and then he has a
heart attack in a carpet store and then
he goes back to the carpet store and he
comes out and Rick says to him uh never
go back to the carpet store Morty and
then he gets in and this crowd sort of
gets around his VR thing and they say oh
my God he's taken uh he's taken Roy off
grid Roy doesn't even have a social
security number and it always makes me
think about people that are playing the
game and people who have somehow managed
to break the thermodynamics of the game
and the thermodynamics of the game like
a a a good person that I think is at
least in part broken them uh Ryan
holiday and Tim Ferris both come to mind
really how so because I I I I'm I'm not
that close but I know both of those
people how how so so Ryan appears to be
someone who is was purposefully kind of
like Cameron Diaz
um reduced the trappings of Fame uh
ramped up Simplicity as best he can and
he'll have his demons and goblins and
all the rest of it right just like the
rest of us and there's layers and layers
and layers of of whatever self-work to
to get to um but it seems to me like he
uh purposefully leans into uh doing
Simplicity like he has his routine he
knows kind of where his his mission lies
and that seems to work the same with Tim
that you know Tim has largely taken a
pretty big step back from Super public
life you know he's not guesting on tons
of podcasts it doesn't seem like he's
writing a book at the moment or at least
he hasn't done for a little while you
know he still does his show but even
that it's you know it's not so much
about the YouTube and the and the
Instagram stuff it's like his audience
and he owns this part of of of the audio
stuff um you know I remember reading 13
reasons not to get famous one of my
favorite ever blog posts by him it's so
great it's so great I I I I take back I
thought you were using those people as
examples of people who got trapped in
the fame but you're you're using them as
examples of the opposite yes uh yeah I
agree the Tim's post on 13 reasons not
to get famous will make your jaw drop
it's a [__] Masterpiece it's great
and you read there's nobody who will
read that and and disagree with what
he's saying like there is a massive
downside to fame that I think once I
don't want to speak for him but I think
once he experienced it he pushed back at
pushed back at it in a pretty successful
way yeah it's very interesting um but
yeah the power leads to success because
it keeps you on your toes thing kind of
also comes back to what we were saying
earlier that um the people who we most
admire are the ones who have the least
admirable internal States right if you
were to trade places with the texture of
Elon Musk or Kim Kardashian or Conor
McGregor's mind you would probably not
fot the bill for the price that you'd
have to pay and again hidden observable
metrics again this is why I love the the
fact that these threads all tie together
even though they're disparate ideas
there's a narrative that kind of weaves
them all together and fundamentally it's
our stupid desire for recognition and
Accolade and Prestige and to be you seen
and validated by the world and to be
slightly higher than the people that are
around us there's this idea I meant to
say earlier on uh intergenerational
competition Theory have you heard of
this no so um it describes a situation
where one of the biggest predictors of
your quality of life especially when you
smear it across an entire nation is how
does this generation compare to its
parents generation at the stage of life
that it's at and you know we've heard
it's been a bit of a metameme for a
while you know like Millennials were the
first generation to not do better than
their parents but really with Gen Z I
think that that is being felt very very
closely and even if the um raw facts and
data when it comes to uh cost of living
minus inflation plus wages and all of
the rest of it even if that kind of ends
up not making too much of a difference
the way that it seems I'm never going to
be able to buy a house people are
staying in the house you know the most
common living arrangement for a man
under 30 is still being at home with his
parents right right and I think I think
social media plays such a massive role
in this of just who you're comparing
yourself to now is a curated algorithmic
highlight reel of the fake scenes in
other people's lives and that becomes
your Baseline to compare yourself
against two and I I see this in my own
life of like when I was growing up my
definition of rich was the people who
bought new pickup trucks and and a
normal person drove a used pickup truck
and you compare that to the current
generation that grew up with YouTube and
Tik Tok and Instagram whatnot their
expectations are in a different Universe
compared to my generations and and your
and your generation and like what is
that going to do to their well-being
their psychological well-being you know
it's not going to be good and the people
who studied this Jonathan height of of
NYU of like teenage depression and
suicide side exploded when social media
came out particularly when it came out
on mobile devices not not went up a
little bit it went vertical during those
periods and I still feel like we're
probably in the early a the early
Innings of that cycle yeah I would agree
and so it's it's it's pretty scary
particularly as as a parent of two young
kids who are you know four and eight
what is what is their generation going
to be like when they're 17 after they
grown up influenced by social media in
such a profound way what we've been able
to facilitate is is uh industrial stale
scale comparison yes that's that's
fundamentally what social media I think
you I think you I think you could take
it one step further and say industrial
scale anxiety is what it produces that's
really what it was it's designed to make
you look at other people yeah it's
designed to make you look at other
people and feel a little bit worse about
yourself I looked at this study from
Finland this week it was in my
newsletter that
um worked out that 15% around about 15%
of the increase in young female mental
health adverse mental health outcomes
can be attributed to uh use of hormonal
birth control and I'd said this when I
first learned about the impact of
hormonal birth control on uh developing
brains maybe about a year ago I just
sort of got it in the back of my mind
and I meant to tell Jonathan about it
because I I don't know if anyone has
like factored in the base rate of the
increase in contraceptive pill use among
young teenage girls uh so there's a a
Confluence of different things
conspiring to try and and damage the
mental health of everybody but yeah man
it's it's it's not good and and you know
from a comparison perspective think
about it yourself think about how you
feel I call it postcontent Clarity like
after you've spent a good bit of time on
your phone like you know if you watch
one type of
thing reading a BL reading a a
collaborative fund blog or something and
I'm like oh like you know I've spent
five minutes reading this reading this
thing what how do I feel after that do I
want to ring my mom do I want to go
outside do I feel like the world is
actually working with me as opposed to
against me have I got agency or after I
watched some panel argument about
politics or something I I want to just
you know curl up in a ball and I want to
eat [__] food and I don't want to tell
anyone that I miss them and you know
that that very much is The Duality of of
the internet and we always justify the
toxic
elements that we spend our time on by
the needles in hay stacks that we
sometimes find as my dad would say a
streak of piss in a pile of [__] I love
it this is true like I I I definitely
feel like modern politics is explicitly
designed to piss you off and once you
realize that that's the game it's like I
it's not a game like who would want to
voluntarily play that game of which you
are guaranteed to wake up every morning
and read your news uh site of choice for
it to explicitly just make you a little
bit angrier at the other half of the
country once you frame it like that it's
like why would you voluntarily play that
game I'm going to choose to play a
different game too much too soon too
fast a good idea run steroids quickly
becomes a terrible idea yeah there's
this idea of Blitz scaling in startups
which is like and look it it came from
very successful entrepreneurs uh but
it's this idea of like however fast
you're growing like do it faster like
like whatever good idea you have like do
it 10 times better 10 times faster like
go go go go go and I think with blitz
scaling usually comes Blitz failing like
there there there's a natural rate at
which anything in investing or business
or life relationships should go and if
you try to push it past that it's going
to break particularly true for
relationships like like there's a
natural rate in which you should go from
meeting someone to marrying them I have
no idea what that natural rate is g to
be different for everyone but the extent
that you're trying to push it further
and faster than it's going to go it's
always going to lead to disappointment
so I think just understanding the
natural rate at which these things need
to grow to grow at and realizing that if
you push them faster it's all going to
break it's so important it's really
important in investing where I I I said
one time the fastest way to get rich is
to go slow because that's that's what
always gets people that's what always
throws people off it's like they get
this investing strategy or they're
they're good at they're good at picking
stocks whatever it is and then their
natural intuition is like great now
let's do it faster I can earn 10% a year
like how do we get to 20 I can earn 20
how do we get to 40 and that's that's
going to blow up 10 times out of 10 like
the natural rate of how fast you should
grow your wealth for the huge majority
of people is probably between 5 and 10%
per year that's the natural rate and if
and your ab your willingness to push it
beyond that is is is is eventually going
to go over the cliff and like if you
stay in that zone and just keep it going
for your lifetime you win you you win
the game you're GNA compound your wealth
everything's gonna everything's gonna be
great and it's the people who try to
push it beyond that that are always
going to end up as the losers it's like
they don't hit the red
button experiment like that there just
one thing that you don't do and it's
don't push it beyond that and yet the
blowup risk is always a hidden metric
whereas the additional 10% gain that you
got last year is a very observable one
who's uh who's Robert
wlo Robert wow was the tallest human to
ever exist he was I forget the exact
number but I think he was pushing eight
feet tall uh he just an ABS if you look
at pictures of him it it doesn't look
like a human being it looks like a
cartoon he was he had a an abnormality
in his pituitary gland that just
bombarded his body with growth hormone
for his entire life and what what I
wrote about in the book is like if you
if you think about Robert wow he was
eight feet tall he wore I think a size
22 shoe his hand was like 16 inches
across you would think of him as like
the real life version of Paul bunan like
you would think he would be like a
superhuman just like the strongest man
the best athlete and he wasn't he would
he could barely walk he could he could
only walk on crutches and when he did it
it was like this horribly pained limp
that he had he was he's super awkward
walking around like his body just didn't
really work and the takeaway was like
you can't double the size of a human and
expect double the output if you double
the size of the human the entire thing
breaks and you look at this in nature
like most very large animals either have
extremely long skinny legs like a
giraffe or very short stubby legs like a
rhinoceros but if you take a human that
has like medium length legs and you just
say double the size of it it doesn't
work and W he was growing so he died I
think in his late 20s he was very young
and but the scientists and the doctors
who were studying him said if if you
grow much larger simply walking even
with your cane your legs are going to
snap because the like the the mechanics
of the human body just did not support
wow a leg and weight ratio of that
amount and what actually killed him is
almost as tragic like it was so hard for
his heart to pump throughout his
enormous body that he had very very high
blood pressure and that led to an ulcer
and the ulcer got infected and he died
from the infection so and like it's
actually such a tragic story it's
amazing it's like he's always in the
Guinness Book World Records and the like
the he he was a basically a circus freak
during his day but you you read about
this man it's like it's a terrible
terrible tragic life but it's the
starkest example of you can't just
double the size of something and expect
double the output sometimes when you
double size the whole system collapses
yeah there's something about kind of a
survival of the fittest as well though
you've got this example about how trees
grow sometimes and runts get eaten
eventually but then when you force
growth too much that's when it goes
wrong there is definitely something
about um I guess when the when the tide
goes out working out who's swimming
naked so to speak uh I think that's a
useful side effect of growth yeah and
and the same thing with Robert row like
perfectly applies to companies you can't
double the size of a company and expect
just to get double the output because
when you double the size of a company
particularly like a startup goes from 20
employees to 100 employees or whatever
all of the sudden your employee culture
is different your hiring practice are
different you need rules and regulations
you need employee handbook and that
might completely kill the culture that
made the startup successful from zero to
20 employees so knowing the normal
growth rate and the natural size of any
of these businesses is super important
Starbucks is another example I use in
the of like back 15 years ago it was on
this ridiculous growth binge and it was
just like every street corner in the
world needs not just one Starbucks but
two and it found that it completely
oversaturated and it completely killed
the Starbucks experience it went through
this depths of thep spare a couple of
years around 2007 where Starbucks was
really losing its way and it found that
like whatever the natural growth rate
for Starbucks was and whatever the the
the right amount of stories that should
have it went way far beyond that and
needed to pull way back so all these
examples of like successful companies
good companies that try to push it too
hard and it backfires on them those
stories are everywhere what are there
any examples of how this is this would
apply to people's personal lives or the
way that they show up in their
day-to-day
existence I think there's definitely a
case I use the example of Travis
kalanick who is the founder of uber uh
and he later got pushed out of the
company as someone who he had the exact
right personality and management
philosophy to bring Uber from Z to 100
and he was the exact worst person that
you could imagine to bring Uber from 100
to a thousand and so there's a lot of
times where your specific personality is
going to work really well in this
situation and be disastrous in another
and I think that could be true at
different phases of your life if you are
someone who is the life of every party
and you can drink people under the table
and you're loud and you're boisterous
that is an amazing personality when
you're 21 if you are still that person
at 47 it's probably a disaster that's
not the personality you buy in large one
at 47 so sometimes what works in one
area like doesn't scale to other areas
of your own life and if you don't
realize that you can't change course
it's it's a tough road for a lot of
people I love it Morgan housel ladies
and gentlemen Morgan you are one of my
favorite writers I'm so glad that we've
been able to get you back on you're
coming on again in
January I think in January and I I'm I'm
scared to see the the set design that
you pick for me because now I know that
is it is a reflection is this going to
be like some cute tea house that you
bring me too and I'm gonna feel really
bad about who you think I am perhaps
yeah we'll have to wait and see uh but
no dude I I absolutely adore this when's
the book actually out when when does it
get released November 7th November 7th
right this will be out pretty much
around about then everybody needs to go
and buy this book Morgan H's first book
psychology of money was a beast and this
next one is is absolutely phenomenal uh
where should St people go where else
should they go to find out what you do
and follow you I spend most of my time
on Twitter my handle is first and last
name Morgan howel I also have a Young
net experimental podcast called the
Morgan housel podcast I'm still playing
around with it oh yeah Morgan I'll see
you next year thanks Chris if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
subscribe